alright so today I'm going to talk about
some of the usable privacy and security
these that we've done at Carnegie Mellon
and some of the background behind what
what I think is both complicated but
also really interesting and cool about
doing these studies so to start with
have you ever wondered whether there's
anything that we can do to get people to
pay attention to computer security
warnings our people willing to pay for
privacy why do people keep posting
things on Facebook that get themselves
into trouble our passphrase is really
easier for people to remember than
passwords over the past decade or so my
students and I have been conducting
usable privacy and security studies to
investigate these and other questions
we've used a variety of different
methods including surveys interviews
field studies online studies laboratory
studies many of them involve a little
bit of deception we draw a lot of what
we do from other fields usable privacy
and security as a new field but it's
actually kind of a mash-up of a lot of
other things and we keep coming up with
new ways to to solve the uniquely the
unique problems in usable privacy and
security our research has covered a wide
range of topics we published a lot of
papers on passwords we've published a
lot of papers on privacy policies and
those are kind of our more recent work
today I mean to give you kind of a
whirlwind tour through a lot of the
different types of work that we've done
and hopefully convince you that this is
an exciting area and that you might want
to do some work in this area as well it
so I'm going to start with a very brief
usable privacy and security studies 101
then I'm going to talk about some work
on evaluating security warnings then
we'll talk about privacy indicators and
willingness to pay for privacy then
we'll talk about some of our work on
privacy nudges and finally we will look
at
privacy at past passwords versus
passphrases and the xkcd cartoon that I
showed you a minute ago so the start
with usable privacy and security studies
101 okay so why should we do usable
privacy and security studies so this is
very similar to why we do any kind of
HCI related studies sometimes we do
these studies to assess needs so that we
can figure out what it is we should be
building sometimes we have a system and
we want to evaluate it we want to
determine whether the system actually
meets the needs and meets the
requirements and where it can be
improved sometimes we conduct these
studies to understand trade-offs decide
which particular approaches are best
going to meet our needs and then finally
we have studies that are aimed at
finding root causes so we know we have a
problem we know that the system is not
working that users can't use the system
but we don't know is why it's failing
and so we do these studies to try to
find out what the root cause of failure
is now there are a lot of great excuses
for not doing usability studies and here
are some that i've heard people actually
say in this area yes if people weren't
so lazy or stupid or careless the system
would work just fine it's the problems
not the system it's the people I'm a
cryptographer not a usability expert
don't look at me I already know what
people want no need to study it I know
exactly what we need that we don't have
time we don't have money we've got to
get on with building the system I find
the system easy to use so it must be
usable or even better my kids can use
the system so it definitely must be
usable this is my son he's actually 14
now but but you know at the time he was
too and he was using a computer so if I
were going to measure the usability of
systems based on what my son who's been
using a computer sent age too
do I don't think that really matches
members of the general public
necessarily here are the rest of my kids
because it wouldn't be fair not to show
them but seriously about kids this this
is an image from an actual paper this
was published at the usenix security
symposium in 2004 now using security is
like one of the top conferences in
computer security right so this is a
really good conference and this paper is
otherwise a fine paper but it has i'm
going to read to you something that says
in this paper while a full usability
test is beyond the scope of this paper
we did perform a very informal usability
test wesley vanderburgh age for created
the drawing in figure 5 wesley is in
many respects representative of
potential end users for EWS then they go
on to say on a more serious note the
window system described here has been
used in presentations to DARPA without
difficulty or noticeable interactive
performance deficiencies right so you
know to be fair this is a systems design
paper it's not a user interface or
usability paper but the authors felt
obligated to say something about
usability in this paper and so instead
of just adding a limitation section and
saying limitation we haven't tested the
usability yet and somebody should do it
in the future instead they added a
section where they kind of pretended
that they had studied the usability when
I I think that that most people would
probably agree that this is not an
acceptable usability study so I'm hoping
that that in the future we will see
better okay another thing that those of
you in HCI are probably familiar with is
you are not a typical user you can't
draw too many conclusions based on your
own experience and here's an example of
where I found that out in one of my
first user studies back in 2002 we did
to study on a tool called privacy bird
so I people into the lab and I
playing to them that we were going to
test a tool it was a web browser plugin
and it would read privacy policies
automatically and tell you whether the
privacy policies matched your personal
privacy preferences and I showed them
the pictures of these two icons now I
didn't put the captions on and i just
showed them those pictures and i asked
them if they could guess what they
thought these icons actually meant and i
was surprised at their responses i had
quite a few people who looked at the
green bird and said oh quite obviously
this is at websites where you can
download music and the red bird was
clearly sites that you don't want to let
your kids go to all right so once people
said it yeah it became obvious to me why
they were saying that and but until I
started hearing this from not just one
participant about multiple participants
it had completely not occurred to me
that this would be something that people
would would think when looking at these
icons so so that really reinforced that
you can't just you know look at it
yourself that you really do need to test
things with other people okay so when
you conduct a user study a lot of people
here have conducted user studies so I'm
not going to go into details when I when
I talk to security audiences I have to
kind of go through all this but you know
kind of the high level so you know you
decide what it is you're going to study
you decide on what kind of study you're
going to conduct and design the protocol
then you've got lots of scripts and
scenarios and incentives prototypes
recruiting materials all of that you've
got to come up with you have to go to
IRB then you do some piloting and you
iterate you collect some data you
analyze your results and then you find
out that there were problems and you go
through and repeat some of these steps
until you finally have a study that's
complete enough that you can write a
paper okay so this is pretty familiar as
far as usability studies go when we're
looking specifically at usable privacy
and security studies
there are some additional design
challenges that that you don't always
have in your typical HCI study so one
big issue that we have is ecological
validity keeping it real and part of the
problem we have here is that we want to
test how our systems fair generally when
they're being attacked right when when
there's some risk right but we can't
actually put our participants at actual
risk because we'd hurt them right so we
can't do that so we have to make it
realistic for the participants and make
them feel like they might be when
they're at risk but without hurting them
and with also without biasing them to
know that that's particular what we're
studying it's also important that we
measure the right thing and it's not
always obvious what the right thing to
measure is and I'll show you some
examples of where that gets difficult
we're also looking at things where
they're not necessarily frequent
occurrences so we have a piece of
software that we want to see what
happens when the software detects a
security or privacy attack and notifies
the user well it's not going to be
constantly detecting these attacks so in
a real world scenario you wouldn't
expect the user to be warned you like
three times in a one-hour session that
would actually be an unusual thing and
so it becomes difficult to figure out
how to study these things realistically
and have enough incidents to study and
then we have legal ethical and practical
issues okay so I'm going to start with
our security warning studies and
illustrate some of these so you all have
probably seen security warnings that
looks something like this and you don't
really have to read them because you
know what they say something happened
and you need to click OK to get on with
doing things right and it has a bunch of
technical crap all right and so people
generally respond by swatting them away
and so what we wonder is how can we get
users to pay attention to these
dialogues so we
it by looking in particular at fishing
warning dialogues so most web browsers
have these warnings that will pop up
when the web browser has detected that
this might be a phishing website and the
these are what they looked like back in
2007 when we did this study so our first
challenge in designing this study was
how can we observe users interacting
with these warnings without them knowing
that what we're interested in is these
warnings and how can we make them feel
like they're under an attack a phishing
attack without actually putting them at
risk so we decided to do a deceptive
study so we invited people to our lab
for a study on online shopping and we
told them that they were going to have
to buy some paper clips from amazon com
why paper clips because they're cheap so
we could afford to have people buy paper
clips on Amazon so we had them actually
log on to Amazon and purchase a box of
paperclips and then we handed them a
paper survey about online shopping it
was actually a real survey that somebody
else was doing about online shopping at
CMU so they filled out that survey while
they were doing that we fished them and
then we told them to check their email
and get their receipt for the purchase
so we could print it out and reimburse
them for their paper clips when they
went to do that they saw a email that
looked like it was from Amazon actually
we had sent it as a fake phishing attack
and that would attract their attention
they would go read it and hopefully fall
for it so this was the email they got
and the key thing is that it says please
approve this delay so that we can
continue processing your order note if
we haven't received your approval by the
end of business tomorrow the item will
be cancelled alright so it's basically
something has gone wrong with your order
you've got to do this you've got to
click on this link and the link that we
gave them was this link so it goes to ww
amazon accounts net right and we didn't
use any
fancy tricks it was just in plain text
right there in the email and and so our
hope was is that people would click on
that that would attempt to load the
phishing website in the web browser and
the web browser fishing warning would
jump in and they get a warning and then
we could watch and see what happened
when that morning appeared what the
people do yeah your site or was it
embarrassing since we actually
registered that site then you how did
you get that browser to report we talked
to the browser vendors and have them add
how to add it to their list of known
phishing sites yeah yeah so there were
there were a lot of practical issue here
rectilinear so the other thing though is
that then the anti phishing email system
started snagging our emails so that our
recipients didn't even get the email so
then we had to get them to whitelist our
site and then the Amazon lawyers called
the CMU lawyers because they saw we had
registered amazon accounts net and they
said well that's a trademark and these
people are probably up to no good so we
what we ended up doing is we made it so
you could only see that domain from on
campus at CMU then the lawyers were okay
with it alright so it took us a while to
work out all these details and make it
so that would actually work but
eventually it worked and it was
successful and by success by success I
mean most of the participants got
phished not with what we were looking
for but we we tested this with with
several different browsers and warnings
and we were able to see a significant
difference between conditions so what
warning we showed people made a
difference and that's what we were
trying to observe and measure um we also
were watching people to see what
happened we when when they were going
through this so that we could understand
the people who ignored the warnings why
were they ignoring the warnings what was
the root cause of the failure
with those warnings so I don't have time
to go into all the details but a few
interesting highlights one is that they
were pretty confused by domain names we
actually had one participants say the
address in the browser was of was of
amazon accounts net which is a genuine
address right so people couldn't tell
that that wasn't amazon amazon accounts
it sounds like amazon this is a good
good URL we also found that their mental
models were very different than that of
experts so we had some users who when
that warning popped up they closed the
web browser they went back to the email
they clicked on the link again the
warning popped up they closed the web
browser and they kept repeating this
cycle like seven or eight times so then
at the end in our debriefing interview
we asked them what were you doing what
was going on and what we found is that
the model that people had was there's
something wrong with the website the web
browser is just giving me some warning
when web browsers give me warnings it's
usually because something's wrong with
the website and usually if you just keep
trying again eventually it fixes itself
and it will be fine they had no idea
that it was something dangerous with the
website and that it had something to do
with the email because the warning
wasn't in their email client it was in
that web browser so that was that was an
interesting insight that we got from
from doing this study as a result of
this we came up with a bunch of
recommendations for the browser vendors
of the warnings and this is one of the
the new warnings that came out after our
study that was influenced by the study
so it was pretty cool to actually have
have an impact there then we went on to
look at ssl certificate warnings and
trying to figure out how to design a
better certificate warning and this
actually started as a class project in
one of my classes and then these two
students went on to the ph.d program and
one of them is since graduated okay so
with ssl certificate warning yeah
game changes really make between the
original and the one that you came up
with the warning dialog Oh so some of
the changes had to do with making the
dialogue look different than the typical
dialogue so there are a lot of dialogues
that that pop up and they're really not
all that dangerous and the fishing
warning is almost always right it almost
always is fishing and it and it is
dangerous and so we said you know do
something like make the background read
so you can immediately see this is
different from the other warnings that
you have we also had thinks about being
very direct in the wording and things
like that okay so yeah so so when we're
looking at SSL warnings our problem is
is that the SSL warnings are a category
of warning that often there isn't
actually any danger you get a lot of
them you swat them away it doesn't
matter but sometimes there is danger and
as a user you actually have to
distinguish between the dangerous and
the not dangerous so in the physical
world there are some hazards that are
always dangerous so you should never put
your baby in a coffee pot you should
never drink poison and you should never
enter you know old abandoned mines like
these things are always dangerous okay
but there are other hazards that are
actually context dependent so wine for
most people drinking wine in moderation
is not dangerous but if you are about to
drive a car or if you are pregnant then
you probably shouldn't be drinking wine
and hopefully you know the context to
determine whether in this context for
you today whether drinking wine is
dangerous or not dangerous now our
problem with computer security dialogues
is that users often are not well
equipped to evaluate that context and
determine whether it's dangerous or not
dangerous and software developers kind
of take the easy way out and anytime the
the relevant exception is triggered in
their code they say hey we're going to
just throw up a warning and let the user
figure it out so what we really want is
a warning that would actually help you
users figure out whether they are likely
to be at risk or not so that if there is
an actual risk they can stop what
they're doing but if there's no risk
they can proceed with what they're
trying to do without the warning really
getting in the way and so what we
realized is that when we're evaluating
these warnings and their effectiveness
we need to evaluate them in both a risky
and a non risky context to make sure it
works in both contexts so we did a study
we came up with two context the non
risky context was the Carnegie Mellon
library website so at that time Carnegie
Mellon had a self-signed certificate and
so every time you tried to go to the
Carnegie Mellon library you got a
warning in your web browser and CMU
students new to just swat it away and
proceeded to the library so not risky on
the other hand if you are going to your
online bank account to login you should
not get that kind of warning if you do
you should be afraid it probably is an
attack going on so we wanted to have
people log into their online bank
account in our lab and check their
account balance and in order to do that
we had to simulate a man-in-the-middle
attack so that a warning would pop up in
the web browser and in order to simulate
a man-in-the-middle attack we had to
effectively do a man-in-the-middle
attack and we figured out how to do it
in a way that we thought was safe
however the CMU lawyers were not so sure
and they told us that this may or may
not actually be legal in the state of
Pennsylvania yeah so it has to do with
wiretapping laws and things like that
many months and conversations with
lawyers later we had a new plan so what
we ended up doing was removing the root
certificate from the web browser which
would cause a warning to pop up at all
secure websites and that way we didn't
actually have to do a man middle attack
and it all worked out okay so we were
doing this as a lab study and we
had some other challenges to overcome
one problem is that in the lab study
people are often going to feel pretty
safe like they know that we're a nice
University and we're not going to hurt
them and so if even though they're at
their online bank and this warning is
popping up they might figure well you
know these researchers wouldn't do
anything bad to me so it's probably
nothing they also their main priority is
just to finish this really quickly and
get paid and so if this morning pops up
and then they would have to like stop
and figure out what else to do right
they might say I'm not going to bother
because it's just going to take me
longer to finish the study so what we
did is we came up with easy alternative
tasks so we ended up having in the study
for tasks one of them was check your
online bank account one was to go to the
CMU library and look up a book and then
we had two other tasks that we didn't
actually care about and didn't involve
any warnings and for each task we gave
them instructions for how to do it
online and how to do it by phone and we
had a laptop and a phone sitting on the
desk right and so most people are trying
to do everything online because it's
faster and you don't have to call people
right but if a warning pops up they
could very easily switch and use the
phone to get the answer so what happened
we had 100 users come to our lab and we
tested this with firefox to firefox 3
internet explorer 7 and 2 new warning so
we had five different warnings we found
that in internet explorer 7 and firefox
to most users ignored all the warnings
whether at the library or the bank they
just ignored them firefox 3 was really
interesting it had just come out at the
time and people couldn't ignore the
warnings they couldn't figure out how to
ignore the warnings
it was like this multi-step process to
get rid of the warning and people just
didn't know what to do and so even at
the library they couldn't figure out how
to get how to ignore the warning so that
was not a successful design either the
warnings that we made up did a lot
better most people ignored the warnings
the library and about half of them
ignored the warnings to the bank so half
of them actually heeded the warnings of
the bank so this is a big improvement
this is a huge success but we still had
half the people who would have been
attacked had the attack been real so
much better than the old warnings but
hardly something you can completely
declare a victory about right so then we
went on to do some other warning studies
we realized that one of the key things
that differentiated experts in lay users
is that when you showed experts a
warning they tended to be able to say
yeah I look right here and this tells me
whether whether i should worry about
this or not and lay users had no idea so
we said well maybe if we highlight that
key piece of information that the
experts are looking at so here's an
example so one of these is risky and
what is not you guys see with which is
the risky one in case you don't so the
name of the publisher there is the
important piece of information that that
you need to look at all right so we said
okay let's do a study where we try
different ways of attracting people's
attention to the name of the publisher
that's that's the key bit of information
so we came up with different types of
attractors to attract their attention
yeah registering like that how to
register a fake name microsoft oh it's
pretty easy to register one that looks a
little bit like microsoft you're not
supposed to be able to register actual
microsoft although occasionally that
happens too but most of the time if it
says microsoft it really is microsoft
but if it says something a little bit
off then yeah it's not yeah okay so we
came up with a bunch of different visual
attractors which i'll show you we
also thought of the idea of forcing a
delay before people could proceed and do
the the Unruh see things so like a
five-second delay we also saw did the
idea of forcing some kind of an
interaction and then the other thought
we had was how can we force users to
read the publishers name now for those
of you who teach if you could find a way
to force students to read anything like
you'd be really happy right and I have
yet to find a way of forcing students to
know reliably let they read something
but we actually came up with an idea
here so here are some examples this was
our ansi standard warning colors this is
what you see on those caution warnings
it's really ugly but maybe it will
attract people's attention then we did
this animated connector thing and we
thought well maybe that would attract
attention or the slow reveal then we did
this one we're in order to get people to
read we say what if you can't do the
unsafe thing until you actually swipe
your mouse over that key piece of
information and we thought you know if
you're swiping your mouse over it surely
you're going to read it well we learned
actually that you can swipe without
reading especially if you do it a lot
and then the one that worked out the
best is we said you have to retype that
line right it's really hard to retype
things without reading them it's not
impossible but it's hard so so so that
that those were all things that we
wanted to test so then we had to figure
out a way that we could test these
things and we had we had a number of
requirements for our methodology we were
going to do a lab study again and we
realized we had so many different
conditions we wanted to test that we
would be there like all year running
people through our lab so we decided we
had to do it online we needed to do it
inexpensively quickly we needed to be
able to remotely observe what people
were doing and we needed to give them a
real scenario where they wouldn't know
that we were testing warnings and we
needed to put them at risk without the
I'm really being at risk okay so we used
mechanical turk workers to do the study
and we recruited them for a study on
online games so we told them that this
was an online games evaluation survey
and they were presented with
instructions and told they were assigned
a game so first they were assigned the
mars buggy online game and importantly
we we had the link to the game with this
bit of information the website whose URL
appears above is external to the study
our researchers do not control its
contents because we didn't want them to
feel safe like oh I'm just playing games
for Carnegie Mellon we wanted them to
know these are external games we have no
control over them that was actually a
lie but that's where the deception was
in our study yeah within this particular
case right it looks like the attention
thing is have small font and it's below
i worthy of the highlighted a game sort
of in a box installation how many users
would actually need the thing below
before just clicking on the link so we
we have no way of knowing how many
people you know actually read that it
did say attention in red and things like
that what we do know is that based on
their behavior in the study and in the
way they answered the the the questions
afterwards the users seem to have
believed that they were going to
external website so that was the
important thing yeah it seemed to have
had the desired effect whether they just
figured it out on their own or whether
they read it it had the desired effect
yeah okay so they went and they played
this Mars buggy game and then when they
finish playing the game we gave them a
bunch of questions the first question
was were you able to play the game and
we made it really clear here that if you
couldn't play the game for some reason
we would give you another game to
evaluate and this was really important
because again we needed a way out that
if they were going to stop in the middle
because of a security concern that they
knew that they could continue the study
and still get paid so they would they
would see this with every game that they
played and then we asked them to
describe the game and
you know answer some questions about
whether it was fun and things like that
and there are a whole bunch more
questions and then we go and assign them
another game and this is the Tom and
Jerry refrigerator game they play that
go through the same drill then we get to
the third game and this is the one that
we actually care about in this game when
they go there they are told that they
need to install some extra software in
order to run the game and after a little
while a warning pops up ok and we had we
had all our different warning versions
so subjects were randomly assigned and
they would each see a different version
and half of them would see it in our
benign condition and then half would see
the suspicious condition so this one is
a benign one and then we also had a
suspicious one hey I see soon no I don't
see how did you modify the security
warning it's so ah this is all think
it's all JavaScript if they were
proficient web users many mechanical
tickers are they would realize that like
the window was it was in the same so it
is possible that they might have done
that we did a lot of things to try to
make it really hard to notice so one of
the things we did was we we suggested
that they enlarged their browser to fill
the whole screen which made it a lot
harder to detect we had a nice shadow
going on behind it so it looked like a
real window yeah my student who did this
spent a lot of time making it look
really good so that even experts didn't
immediately go wow that's not real and
we did ask people in our debriefing
survey and very few people actually
figured that out it was it was done well
but yeah that was a concern that that
they might detect it yeah if it were
there be some users instead counselor to
the real one just because they didn't
want to install something yes yes so so
after we saw what they did we gave them
a survey and we asked them why they did
what we they did so that we knew
whether they were like you know I just
don't feel like installing software
today or I'm concerned about the
security yeah yeah yeah so yeah so we
had over 2,200 people who did our study
and got all the way to the third game
where they encountered the dialogues
what we found was that in in most of our
conditions are actually in all of our
conditions in the benign scenario most
people installed the software and
actually nobody was installing anything
but they thought they were going to
install the software and and we saw that
we also measured how long it took them
and so we saw in some conditions it
actually slowed people down and then in
the suspicious scenario it actually
varied quite a bit by condition that
some of these warnings we had people
ignore and others most people actually
stopped and would not install the
software we found that the swype type
and delay were the most effective
approach here but one of the questions
we had was well this is just one
instance of the warning and you've never
seen this warning before so you're going
to have a tendency to be surprised that
it's there and you might be paying more
attention so what would happen if you
saw this warning repeatedly would that
make a difference and so we conducted
some more experiments here we couldn't
come up with a plausible way to have
people exposed to lots and lots of
warnings and so we gave up on that and
instead we we gave them the scenario of
your job is just the swat away warnings
so keep swatting away warnings and at
some point we may tell you that you can
stop and end the study early and still
get paid and so basically we had at some
point the warning said you know press
this button to end the study and we
wanted to see if they notice that in the
morning and so here's here's a graph
that shows you what happened so across
the bottom you see the number of
exposures to the warning and you can see
that the more exposures they had the
less likely they were to notice when we
changed the warning this was you know a
dreadfully dull stuff
I have to swat this away 200 times so
the red lines are our control condition
and our ASCII condition that had had a
am c condition that had that black red
and yellow warning yeah all the time
mm-hmm this actually jumped around the
screen yeah we hadn't randomly jumper on
the screen yep okay the purple lines
here were were two of our other warnings
you could see they did a little bit
better but still dropped off and then
the last the green lines these are our
type and swipe you can see they did a
lot better to start with but they also
didn't have the drop off and that was
really significant and it wasn't until
we'd actually gone and done our third
study where we specifically designed the
study to look at that drop off that we
finally you know got to the bottom of it
and saw the the flaws and all the other
warnings yeah well what is completed it
was the very mature we're measuring
whether they the first time it said you
can click this other button to end the
study whether they they did that or
whether they kept swatting it away for a
while until they notice that they that
they could stop yeah yeah yeah all right
so switching gears a little so we were
also we've also looked at privacy
indicator so we were talking about
security now we talked a little about
privacy and we wondered whether if you
give people information about privacy
they would pay to protect their privacy
yeah for this a question about studies
because you know what to go to study
there are like tackling these are not
their personal computers but those are I
know this was online so it was their
computer yeah so some of the studies
were that's true it was in the lab but
the yeah this last one was online and it
was their computer yeah yeah good
question yeah okay so we were wondering
whether if we make it really obvious
what what websites have better privacy
whether people would pay to protect
privacy yeah
what do you have is there a chance that
there's a significant drop off bridge
which sort of effect edge of the balance
though I mean it's a user's might sort
of get frustrated after a more hundred
or whether they were actually pretty
yeah we looked at that and I don't
remember off the top of my head but we
we didn't have you use numbers of people
who dropped out yeah I mean they dropped
out early on once they saw what a
terrible task it was but once people got
started they were invested I've got to
get my two dollars or whatever it was we
paid them yeah so okay so we built a
search engine that had privacy meters in
it you'd see them along the side that
would tell you about the privacy policy
of websites and we wanted to see would
that actually influence what websites
people visit it and so we thought about
how to do this study and our first idea
was to have a hypothetical task so we
would ask people search for a product
and then tell us which website you would
purchase it from and the problem is that
it's not a real privacy trade-off
because there's nothing to lose by
saying yeah I'll just buy from the best
privacy site right because they're not
actually going to spend their money and
do that so we decided we needed to have
a real task where people would actually
go and use their own credit cards and
purchase products so this is more
expensive because we have to reimburse
them even if you have them by paper
clips it does start to add up if you do
this enough and it becomes difficult to
control because real websites like
change their prices and change their
products and things like that so this
took us a while to get right we had a
series of studies on this the first one
was power strip prophylactics and
privacy oh my which had a great title of
paper and and this was a study that we
actually did in our lab with students
and we paid them ten dollars to come and
buy something online and we reimburse
them for what they bought half of them
were using our privacy finder search
engine and half of them were using the
exact same search engine but without the
privacy information it was real
websites real products the only thing
that we had fixed was what search
results returned it always returned the
same search results that that was we
were holding constant we need we wanted
to have them purchase some typical items
that were not too expensive and then
some privacy sensitive items so this is
what we had some people bought power
strips and then we had the prophylactics
and we told people they had to use their
credit cards but if they wanted to have
the item shipped to our lab instead of
to their homes they could do that and so
yeah this was the floor of my lap and
for the first study this is what the
search engine looked like we had green
happy birds and red mad birds depending
on whether you had good or bad privacy
and we were able to show that the
privacy icons actually influence
people's purchases but we had a lot of
limitations on this study so our
participants were all students we
realized that because we were
reimbursing them regardless of how
expensive it was it wasn't really
incentivizing savings we didn't have a
real obvious price privacy trade-off
because you had to go look up the price
add in the cost of shipping things like
that it could also be that people were
influenced by the indicator but not that
it was about privacy and we were
concerned especially with the student
population that our privacy sensitive
item may not have been sensitive enough
right so we did it again this time we
went outside the university so we
recruited 72 Pittsburgh residents from
around the city we change things so that
the brow the search engine actually
showed you the price including shipping
in the search box we gave them a fixed
payment and told them to keep the change
and we came up with new icons new
products new conditions in order to come
up with the products we actually did a
pre study to find out what people would
consider sensitive to buy while
participating in a study in the Carnegie
Mellon lab
and so this is these are all the things
that we tested in the survey and we
settled on office supplies is something
not privacy sensitive and sex toys as
something privacy sensitive we pick sex
toys because people would be concerned
but they wouldn't refuse to do it and it
turns out that sex toys come in a
variety of prices and so we were able to
find some inexpensive ones that could be
purchased from many different websites
so there we go the pocket rocket jr. it
was so we selected ten merchants for
each product that we're on our search
results screen that people got we made
sure there were no well known merchant
so that we wouldn't have a brand effect
and we we designed our search results so
that the top search result was always
the website that had the item for the
lowest price and the worst privacy and
as you went down the page you got better
privacy more expensive for the first
four search results and people very
rarely ever pick be on the first four
yeah when you see a bright as he scored
seven does that mean it's kind of good
revenuers and another ? sorry that's the
unknown privacy sorry yeah yeah okay so
our this is what our privacy condition
looked like and you can see that we had
these privacy meters and you could click
on and get a privacy report and then we
had a condition which we called
irrelevant information and that was
labeled handicapped accessibility rather
than privacy and in another pretest we
found that handicapped accessibility was
something nobody cared about in this
context and then we had the no
information condition alright so here we
we found that indeed people were
purchasing where the price was lowest
when there was no privacy information or
handicapped accessibility information
when there was privacy information a lot
of people were choosing to pay more for
privacy so that was a much stronger
result than we had on the first paper
but we weren't seeing much of a
difference between products and we
thought perhaps it was because we hadn't
properly controlled the privacy premium
these websites were changing their
prices on a regular basis and in general
the privacy premium the difference
between the lowest and the highest price
was much bigger for the sex-toy than it
was for the batteries that we had people
purchase yeah being reimbursed I've got
the more expensive so they were getting
a fixed payment and they could keep the
change so the fixed payment was large
enough to cover the most expensive one
but they would have less money that they
could keep right all right so we did the
study again this time we contacted the
vendors to get them to hold their prices
constant throughout the study we also
asked them to change their prices at 25
cent increments so to fit what we wanted
to make it really clear one of my poor
students had to call a lot of sex toy
vendors and try to convince them to do
this and and in most cases they were
raising their prices and they agreed but
there was one that had to lower their
prices and so she said well we'll cover
the difference and that was fine she
committed me to doing that at the end of
the study I had to get Carnegie Mellon
to send the dirty bunny one hundred and
forty dollars and they did all right but
all this work paid off we were actually
able to demonstrate that the privacy
sensitive nature of the product did
actually make a difference once we
finally controlled everything properly
but it was a huge amount of work okay
real quick we've been looking at privacy
nudges so the idea behind a nudge is
that rather than forcing people to do
something you kind of nudge them and
this is something the economist's have
been talking about and we're seeing
these you know steps that nudge you to
take the steps rather than the escalator
and all sorts of other examples of real
world nudges so we were looking at
social networks and what do people
regret doing on social networks we
started by studying that we collected
several hundred anecdotes of things
people regretted doing on facebook then
we did it on Twitter lot lots of fun
anecdotes if you want to read those
papers the
lying causes of regrets that we learned
about a big one with not thinking people
post without thinking often because
they're either very excited or very
angry we also have people who don't seem
to have any awareness about how their
post is going to be perceived I thought
it was funny but my friends were
offended and then people forgetting who
is in their audience I forgot that I'm
friends with my mom my boss my ex a lot
of moms and our anecdotes so our idea
was to nudge people so as to try to
avoid these common things that lead to
regret so we developed a a plug-in for
for facebook on the Chrome browser one
idea was our timer nudge and the idea is
you click post and it actually doesn't
post for 10 seconds so you have a
countdown timer and you can go and
change your post in those 10 seconds if
you want we also had a sentiment nudge
where it analyzed the words and it was a
very primitive algorithm that we used it
turned out not to be very good but the
idea was that it would tell you other
people may perceive your post as
negative or positive or whatever give
you that feedback and then the other one
was the profile picture nudge where it
will randomly take five profile pictures
from people who will see the post so if
you're posting friends it will be five
of your friends if you're posting
friends or friends it will be from the
friend of friends group right and every
time you post you'll see a different
five people and that reminds you about
the people who are in your audience all
right so we did a three week study with
21 participants it was really hard to do
this study we had to recruit people who
primarily post on Facebook from chrome
who were willing to let us basically spy
on them for three weeks and so it was
hard to do and then we also found that
that Facebook changes just about every
day and it would break our our nudges
just about every day and then we weren't
collecting data until we realize that it
had broke in and that we fixed it and
so at the end of the day we we did get
some qualitative data about how people
liked or didn't like our nudges but it
was very difficult to get any
quantitative data we did find that it
seen the picture nudge was influencing
people it was helping to remind them
about who was going to see their posts
the timer nudge was useful because
people like took that deep breath and go
oh wait a minute maybe I should reword
this the sentiment nudge basically just
annoyed people it didn't handle sarcasm
very well either so we decided to fix
some of the problems with our nudges we
combined the the picture nudge and the
timer nudge into one nudge and we we
decided to do a longer study we actually
had a student who we paid every day to
go check facebook and see what changed
overnight and then call up the
programmer and have them fix our nudges
first thing in the morning so that we
could minimize any problems caused by
that and so we were able to keep it
going for six weeks with 28 participants
we we tried again to get quantitative
data but still had a lot of trouble with
that we did get a lot of qualitative
data though where we have examples of
posts that people would type and then
erase we know every time they hit the
Delete key we would see when people
would click post and then you know wait
for the countdown and then you know go
back and change it and we have at the
end we interviewed people and ask them
about some of their posts and asked them
why they changed their mind so we found
that it did encourage people to stop and
think there were some people who who
were still annoyed by it you know we had
one person who said there's no way to
protect people from posting embarrassing
information online while mad or upset
it's human nature to do stupid things
right so not everybody was a fan but
most of our participants actually seemed
to to like this approach and so so we
were able to publish this at Kai and we
demoed it to Facebook and facebook now
has some nudges of their own
on which they've indicated were in part
inspired by our work that was pretty
cool all right last thing i want to show
you so XKCD a few years ago came up with
this cartoon and the key bit of
information here is that the cartoonist
is alleging that a passphrase is going
to be easier for people to remember than
a password and it's just as secure and
our group had been doing password
resource for a while and people saw this
and they said we've solved the problem
you know all you have to do is do what
XKCD says you're like no more need to
research passwords passphrases are where
it's at so we thought that was
interesting and we said well this is a
testable question and so let us do a
controlled experiment and find out
whether passphrases really are all that
and so we wanted to to compare system
assigned passphrases to system assigned
passwords why system assigned because if
you leave people to their own devices to
pick their own passphrases they are not
very random and this only works if you
have truly random pass phrases so
therefore we needed to compare this to
random passwords so we did this as a
mechanical turk study we had about 1,500
participants everybody was assigned one
pass phrase or one password in different
kinds of conditions yeah so when you
proportions the comment this of the word
so so we had a bunch of different
conditions where we did it in different
ways and I'll show you in a minute yeah
all right so we assign them a password
or passphrase we had them type in in a
couple of times we ask them some
questions two days later we emailed them
and ask them to come back and try to
remember it we asked them some more
questions including did you write it
down so that we would know and and then
we paid them okay so we had eight
different passphrase conditions and
three password conditions so here's an
example of a passphrase so these are
this is the
or common words condition we drew this
from I think the hundred eighty-one most
common words in the English language and
we randomly selected from that set and
when we looked at that we said you know
the this doesn't seem very memorable
like the these words are kind of too
common and and don't really work well
together so then we said what if we sort
them by type of speech part of speech
and we draw noun verb adjective noun and
so we had I think this was like the top
200 nouns the top 200 verbs right and we
draw one of each and this seemed maybe
better you know plan build sure power
maybe I would remember that and we had a
bunch of other similar variations that
we tried for system assigned passwords
it was just random characters in order
to have the same strength as the pass
phrases and so it turns out you only
need five random characters to have the
same strength and then we looked at that
and said that doesn't seem very
memorable and we looked in the
literature and discovered a scheme for
pronounceable passwords that someone
actually came up with in the 1970s and
we implemented that that gives you
passwords like this to fruit V and vada
sabe so these are basically you start
with a database of syllables and you
randomly select syllables and put them
together and you and you get these words
alright so what did we get well we found
that XKCD is actually not exactly right
on this there wasn't a clear user
favorite we found that people didn't
find pass phrases to be significantly
better or different from random
passwords we found with passphrases
people made more mistakes typing them in
because they're longer and it took them
longer to type them in we did come up
with an error correction scheme so that
we could correct a lot of those errors
without decreasing security so if you
implemented that that would actually
help we found the pronounceable
passwords which my students hated but
actually our users liked they were
faster to enter with fewer mistakes than
pass phrases and showed some promise the
only
I hope we had four pass phrases and we
haven't done this experiment yet is that
perhaps when you need a much stronger
phrase so that you would have say 20
random characters right that's going to
be really hard to remember in characters
but perhaps a pass phrase which might be
10 random words might still be easier to
remember than 20 random characters but
we haven't actually tested that all
right so I'm going to wrap it up here we
I hope I've convinced you somewhat that
that these studies are interesting and
worth doing if you want to hear more
about this come to soups will be this
summer in Denver and also want to let
you all know that Carnegie Mellon is
recruiting faculty and PhD students and
masters students for our privacy
engineering program we have a program
called societal computing which is kind
of an interdisciplinary program where we
looked at applications of computer
science there's a lot of security and
privacy stuff there but at other areas
as well including energy and things like
that and I will end there and take some
more questions just press pass phrases
or complete sentence exceed might be
easier users to remember but you have to
worry about how much entry fee there is
it yeah so if you let people pick their
own then there'll be complete sentences
but then you lose a lot of entropy
because people tend not to be very
random we're all really bad at doing
random things on her own so people tend
to pick song lyrics jingles from cart
from advertisements things like that
yeah which was you assign complete
sentences you know that was the idea
with the with the noun verb adjective
noun was to kind of make it more like
that it wasn't equally sons and that is
something that if it were a longer thing
and you could get the entropy up there
yeah so that's something that still
could be explored yeah all right let me
put that the one with like the ten
seconds before we post you had a post
now thing
to what extent is that similar to like
the whole like the swaddle dialogues /
are you really sure you want to leave
this file type thing like did people
actually just like not wait yeah that
was interesting so the first time we run
the study most people didn't notice the
post now which was convention we had a
lot of complaints from people who said
this is so annoying I hate having to
wait 10 seconds I you know i wish i
could post now and we're like what you
could write so the second time we made
the button like bigger and brighter and
more obvious and there were some users
who routinely used it but not everybody
and I think not even the majority now of
course this is a small sample size but
but it seemed like a lot of people were
not tempted to just always swat it away
yeah in your presentation about sliding
aware dreams you kept swatting away and
McAfee woman and when I stop to read it
it actually sent click the big blue bum
was that you're doing what do you think
anyone else who heed that warning it was
on like look at me look at me quickly I
was wondering wondering what you were
going for there yeah yeah so yeah that
that's that it wasn't a real worrying
slides yeah well no one of my students
who had done a lot of that work made up
that that kind of fake warning that he
started putting in his presentations a
few years ago so I I stole it yeah yeah
you said your students didn't like the
pronounceable passwords but the users
did why did you students not like them
um because they look at them and they
said these things your vada sabi that
like doesn't really seem like really all
that like pronounceable or memorable or
right and yeah so they just kind of
looked at it and said that that's not
something that I would remember but but
we found that that the users like them a
little bit better than than the
completely random characters it wasn't a
big difference and and they were
certainly easier to type then because
they don't have symbols in them right
they're easier to type than random
characters yeah
here Redbirds and green birds and you
have experience with people recover one
yeah yeah so we did make sure that the
intensities of the red and green were
such that they'd be distinguishable by
by colorblind people but with the
intensity the running read and also the
shape of the bird is completely
different and in them as well so that
you weren't relying on the color yeah so
for the mornings as you said like pop
really a problem because there are so
many like false positives so do you
think that it actually would be good if
browsers kind of like raised the danger
threshold for winning Chevy's a warning
absolutely yeah so one of our
recommendations from that work is
actually to have fewer warnings that you
know there's only so much you can do
with making people notice the warnings
and you know if a lot of these warnings
you don't really need then it makes
sense that people start ignoring them
and so I think it's harder behind the
scenes to you know figure out whether or
not it's really dangerous but it seems
like it's worth doing because if you
have fewer warnings than people are more
likely to pay attention to the ones that
actually are a problem yeah yeah so no
in Google robier and son consult alone a
lot with I guess hey be fastening of
different layouts for warnings and stuff
at large numbers of participants given
their pools yeah do they find things
that are consistent with what you guys
weren't here if they've come move
somebody's dialogue um yeah I think I
for the most part they what they found
has been pretty consistent with what
we've found yeah yeah it's um it's I'm
kind of jealous that they have such a
big you know participant pool to to work
with but they can't do some of the crazy
things that we do because they can't
like go too far from the google look and
feel so we can we can push the envelope
further but they have a bigger set of
users to test it on yeah so do you think
the fingerprint reader is like
iphone solve the password problem
completely year um no yes so the
fingerprint reader on the iphone is not
very secure it's very convenient but
it's not very secure so if what you want
is something to just kind of prevent
like your kids from picking up your
phone and using it it's fine but if you
really are trying to protect your phone
from a serious attacker that fingerprint
reader is not really doing much for you
quality of that particular reader that
concerns you otherwise I mean otherwise
it would be a solution well so so in
general the problem with biometrics is
that the really good ones are very
expensive and you can't put them on
consumer devices because it's just too
expensive yeah we have a biometrics lab
actually in our building at CMU that you
can walk into the room and it can read
your fingerprints from across the room
right but yeah it's super scary uh-huh
but you know that system is like two
hundred thousand dollars right you're
not going to put it in an iphone though
yeah what do you think the future is a
more hybrid hardware or software systems
so first of all I don't know why not you
know my my Apple watch knows when I take
it off and put it on you have to put the
password it but once i have it on why
does that not just allow me to log into
anything that I'm right in the keyboard
of unless it's my bank or something
where I need an extra protection and it
seems like we could be at the point
where you wouldn't give you password for
a lot yeah it will so um there already
some systems that use proximity cards
for I think some government system so
you have your government ID that has I
guess an RFID or something in it and and
and so if you have it well there's some
of them you have to actually stick into
the computer so any time you stick your
card into the computer then you don't
have to log in but there's some now that
if you're like sitting in front of the
computer that you're close enough or the
cars that if the keys are in your pocket
the car starts because
it the proximity so I think we're going
to see more of that it's not it's not a
perfect solution and it's not it doesn't
it doesn't work for all situations but
yeah so there's a study that looked at
what can we do to replace passwords and
basically what what they found is there
is no perfect password replacement that
would just replace all passwords for
some specific situations there are
things that are much better than
passwords but there's no universal
password replacement today yeah this is
all interesting about privacy I wonder
any Studies on surveillance what is the
effect of people if they know that
they're being surveilled how do they
change their behavior their studies on
them so we haven't done Studies on that
but there I I think there are some
studies I can't off the top of my head
tell you what they are but I i think
it's an area that there's been a couple
of studies in but it's a good area to do
more studies and I think it would be an
interesting area yeah I don't know when
we talk about this something you have
plus something you know the thing that's
coming up these days yeah does that sort
of like reduce the requirement for
passwords to be secure I mean some
extent at least yes so if you use
two-factor where it's not just your
password you're relying on but you also
have a token or it's going to text your
phone right then then your password
isn't you know the the the point of
failure so even if somebody gets your
password there's still another layer and
so if you do that then yeah it's less
important for the password to be super
secure it's it's the the second factor
still can be broken as well so you still
want your password to be somewhat secure
but it reduces the importance on that
you say still doesn't remove the need
for passwords company key no because
those second factors none of them are
good enough that that they on their own
provide enough security they went in
combination with a password it's good
but on their own there are still
problems with them yeah
so you know on Facebook um this is a
common phenomenon of like people will
often deletes their things after they
hosted it like few minutes or an hour or
whatever after i'm wondering like the
posts that your system kind of like
catches yeah are those the most people
would have deleted themselves anyhow
such is just like way too late and
that's a good question um yeah I don't
know that our study would have given us
data to know that for sure in one of our
I guess our Twitter regrets study one of
the things we asked people was we ask
people you know tell us about a time
when you posted something on Twitter and
then regretted it and then we asked them
how long after you posted it did you
realize that you regretted it and what
did you do and so we did find that often
the thing they did was delete the tweet
but it often was the next day and the
reason that most people realize they
regretted it was when other people
started tweeting at them or seeing them
in person or whatever and saying what
was that thing you tweeted it and in
that study we also compared that with
conversation conversational regret so we
also ask people what's something you
said in a conversation regretted and
what we saw was in a conversation you
immediately regret it usually because
the person you're talking to starts
frowning or crying in the horse gays or
or hit you right and you immediately
have that regret whereas on Twitter I
the the typical response was I tweeted I
went to bed and I woke up the next
morning to all of this and I go my gosh
I shouldn't have done that I'm gonna get
delete it now yeah sir way back to
mcafee nicon thing worth it are they
there been any new around in specific
studies that have used humor or like
flippant language as a way of getting
people's attention like it if that's
counterintuitive the kind of the gravity
of security or not yeah so I don't know
of any published study that's done that
but that's something that we're looking
at we're in the process of trying to
build a better password meter
because we we've done some studies on
how well the meters actually get people
to make stronger passwords and most of
them are out there right now are not
very good so last year in my usable
security class for a class project
students were looking at different
wording you could put on so instead of
just saying good or bad you know what
does it say that's a stupid password
only an idiot would have a password like
that so we didn't publish it was just a
little a class project thing but what
they found is that in general the humor
was kind of helpful as long as you don't
go too far with it their line could be
cross there but but some humor did have
the effect of kind of attracting
people's attention to pay attention to
it yeah one thing probably my
undergraduate class with humor and
dialogue is that it could be very
culturally situated and whether that's
negative or especial it up multi-picture
society yeah I think that that it could
make a difference and I mean once you
get to the the cultural things yeah it
like nudges I heard there was a study on
Facebook has a thing that if you want
someone to untag you from a post you can
like click and and it will like send
that person a message to you please
untag me and they actually have
different messages in different
countries and so in some countries it
says you know I would please I would
really appreciate it if you don't tag me
right and in others it's like much more
direct like I demand that you had AG me
because they found that culturally some
some countries people are going to
respond to the polite requests and some
it's the demand is going to be better
yeah one more question so he talks a lot
about nudging people to pay attention to
these notifications I was wondering if
and you've thought about how do people
make sense of the notification so I
might get a notification there's
something wrong with privacy but if I
don't have a benchmark to compare it
against you could there be a bigger
system where I tell my computer this is
how much I care about privacy now tell
me these notifications relative to
what I already know rather than giving
me information that I can't make some
self yeah yes oh so that's on something
that we've actually been looking at as
well as kind of this personalized
notifications we actually a project
called the personalized privacy
assistance and the idea is that you can
tell your privacy assistant your
personal levels it can also learn over
time by observing what you're okay with
and what you're not okay with and it
will stop bugging you about the things
that it knows you're okay with or that
it already told you 10 times and you
ignore it anyway or um yeah so that's a
work in progress but yeah we think it's
a good idea I think one more time
you